(simple rhythmic music)
- This is Yuni, a two year old binturong.
With a face like a cat,
a body like a bear,
and a tail like a monkey,
these reclusive creatures
are unlike any other.
Binturongs are native to
the tropical rainforests
of Southeast Asia, and
spend most of their time
high in the treetops.
They are excellent climbers.
Their long prehensile
tails act as another limb
as they move through the trees.
Even when asleep, their tails are anchored
securely around a branch.
The binturongs flexibility
doesn't end there,
their ankles can rotate 180
degrees to maintain a grip,
even when climbing down a tree head first.
Perhaps the most curious
trait of the binturong
is its smell, buttered popcorn.
While pleasing to a human
nose, the binturong’s scent
is a way to mark its
territory and to warn rivals
to move along.
The binturong faces many threats,
the worst being habitat destruction.
Over the past two decades
their population has fallen precipitously.
This is the binturong.
(soft simple music)